Chính phối đuôi xin cho biết giả trình xác làm về tạnh nhà 1 2 1 tận đối cùng trước và khuy nghĩ áp dụng cho khu vực tương nhân, nhằm tiếp kiểm nâng nâng nâng nâng, châu Âi cạnh giá sâu tận cầu tăng cao.
Bình phó này dự kiến sự đường thực hiện sau khi nghĩ lế Êt ăn phía rồi.
Mà đều từ ngày 20 tháng 20 và phóng áp dụng với các lĩnh vực dịch vụ công thiết iếu, giới chức ý nâng đi xin cho rằng việc dạm dí chuyển của thế giúp tiếp kiểm đáng kể như liệu,
đồng thời vẫn bảo đam cân bằng giữa quả công việc và như cầu sả hội, chính xin này cũng được ki vọng gó phần kích thích các họ đồng tư dụng và dư lựa điện.
Không chỉ, nó ni như cua ra châu à phá của năng trình thái các biển pháp tình tự.
Thái lan quyến kích làm về tự xa và giảm tự thủ điện.
Chúng khi phía lý pin giá b dụng tôn làm về hốn ngày trong khu vực công.
Bà ký dạng cũng đăng xem xét các giải pháp, nhưng học và làm việc chịch kiến.
Các đồng thái này cho thấy của bật chua đang tăng cường thịt ổn người biến đọng lực tân cầu,
đồng thời tiêm kiểm giải pháp xa hàng, nhé bảo đam cung địa kinh tế.